if you're empty and you can't find
meaning in other people it being
serviced other people are contributing
to society I don't know what we're we're
doing well welcome I am very excited to
have with me today dr. drew and we'll be
talking with him in just one second but
first look everybody looks better in a
suit dr. drew is the best dressed man on
the planet
but even dr. drew would look great in
endo Chino because endo Chino is the
world's largest made-to-measure menswear
company they've been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes and
Fast Company company they make suits and
shirts made to your exact measurements
for a great fit dudes love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics the
option to personalize all the details
including your lapel your lining your
monogram so here's how it works you can
go to a showroom they have one in
Beverly Hills or they have them all
around the country or it can shop online
at endo Chino com you can pick their
fabric choose your customizations submit
your measurements I've done it myself it
is super cool and then you wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks and it fits you like a glove
this week my listeners can get any amia
mindo Chino suit for just 379 bucks at
Indo chinos calm when you enter
Shapiro's
at checkout again use that promo code
super you get 50% off the regular price
for a made to measure premium suit and
shipping is free so Indo Chino comp
Ramon coach Shapiro any premium suit 379
bucks and free shipping you look like
James Bond but you don't have to be
James Bond prices
it's an incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack could Indo Chino comm use that
promo code Shapiro okay so now dr. drew
thank you for stopping by dr. drew for
those who don't know and you've been
hiding under a rock for the last 20 30
years dr. drew is the original host of
Loveline which is where I first got to
know his work just like everybody else
but he is currently a host over at KBC
in Los Angeles on mid days he also does
five separate podcasts I've got Adam
Andrew good drew we got these whole
patrol just of health and fitness
podcast and another one would Bob for us
got the hat and the glasses I did
Celebrity Rehab with called this life
it's been said mental health and
addiction that kind of stuff so dr. Drew
has a very very full plate
exactly I'm glad he had time say come
over here and I was thinking about as
you were talking about the suits I'm
going to buy by the way too good a deal
though let go but but I want you to
change my mind today I like well
unfortunately we live in a world where
people don't like to change there
I cannot understand that I my mind
changing is how I grow that that's what
I want you to change my mind so well
this is this is why I think this is why
I think someone's you're so popular one
of the one of the reasons that a lot of
people we have on I think are so popular
is because if you view life as a journey
through knowledge I think that you have
a much better time doing it and also
you're less likely to become ticked off
so one of the things that's great about
what you do is that you talk with a lot
of people from a lot of variant points
of view but you're pretty even keel I
mean it's a business degree III the
hubris is the furthest thing from what I
think I should be and when people become
hubristic that's right you're pissed
because the human experience is so
complex and so rich for anybody to stand
off and tell you this is how it's got to
be I just often so before we get into
any of the deep stuff I first want to
get something off the table because
obviously there's an elephant in the
room for those who know our history
together so the first time that we ever
met in person is when I was on your show
back on CNN Headline News and it became
sort of a cause to let because there was
an incident with Zoey terzo heats her as
a transgender woman a man who is in my
opinion believes he has a woman and and
doctor and doctor Drew was hosting the
show and in the middle there was a bit
of a conflagration when he started
calling me and suggesting I was a little
boy and I said what are your genetic sir
not you Zoey and and at that point I
remember you calling her sir and that's
what got her so it started off with me
and talking about genetics and then and
then Zoey saying you don't know anything
about genetics little boy and then me
responding well what are your genetics
sir and that led obviously to this big
kind of blow-up and a national story and
all the rest and the rest is history
and I I didn't produce it and I
apologize to you and to Zoey for putting
you in that position I had no idea that
was the direction it was gonna go but I
I do remember you know I've done a lot
of I've run a lot of groups in my son
and I know what groups are getting out
of control and his potential advise I
know how to jump in I know where to jump
in and and I also know where to let
things kind of play out and I felt
always felt like okay well that's kind
of I'm not quite out of my chair yet on
this one yeah if I if you felt like I
should have been I Pollock oh no no it
wasn't it wasn't on you and I didn't
blame you for any of that it was just a
very weird and odd circumstance I just
wanted to get that one off the table
doctor doesn't bother over each other no
yeah
everything's cool so okay so now I want
to talk a little bit let's just jump
into first some health issues and I want
to get into sort of your personal
philosophy so as a medical doctor and
somebody who as you were telling me
before the show now gets to spend your
days talking about things rather than
working five eight to ten P I want to
ask you about a couple of things that
seem to be plagued in the country so the
opioid epidemic is obviously a major
issue on a lot of people's minds and
there are a lot of debates over the
cause of this upswing and opioid use how
much do you think that the opioid
epidemic is a result of over
prescription from doctors and how much
it is a result of you know the the
influx of heroin into the city and or
more laps book dreamland yes okay that
that is how it happened
Sam Cano his book I talked to Sam and I
what I call him all I said is how did
you how did you get it so right because
I lived through that and I hate that
book describes it accurately it is
mostly perpetrated by my profession if
you look at the history of opiates we've
had two major opioid crises in this
country one was about 1880 after the
Civil War it's when we had the
hypodermic needle we created hibernate
we invented the hypodermic needle and
invented morphine sulfate
these are wonderful drugs for the first
time we could affect human suffering we
got carried away we created a bunch of
addicts we didn't know what to do we
treated it with methamphetamine and
cocaine and all kinds of other crazy
things we've always made the same
mistake which is we become
over-enthusiastic we don't understand
what addiction is we create a diction
and then we try to treat it with other
drugs we've made that mistake many many
times we're doing it again now this time
was extraordinary
there are multiplicity of forces that
came together created there was you know
the the insurance situation syringe
companies sort of took over the practice
of medicine everything had to be very
quick and there's no quicker way to end
an appointment than opening a
prescription pad that and the fact that
a group of physicians decided that they
would stake their reputation on the fact
that opioids are not addictive and you
could treat pain liberally pain became
the fifth vital signs the attorneys got
involved with that and started not just
suing doctors for malpractice but
criminally assuming them Sibley suing
them for inadequate treatment of pain
the state medical boards got involved
the Joint Commission on hospital
accreditation
all these forces came together and said
pain is as important as your pulse
and pain controls but the patient says
it is paying experience what the patient
says it is we have these great medicines
use them and you are a coward you're
actually a dangerous person if you don't
and so I was living through all that
trying to get everybody off them my
peers were putting them on them and I I
just will tell you was a catastrophe and
you would know 90% the opiates on earth
end up being prescribed in this country
and now we're beginning to find our way
out of it what happened was the heroin
problem as it was documented in
dreamland there was a group people
learned how to distribute it very
effectively at a time when my peers were
cutting off patients they were beginning
to learn that oh my god we were creating
drug addicts so as opposed to bringing
the patient into the office and going
look we didn't intend this I didn't mean
to make and had it we have now have a
second problem we have to get this
treated what my peers did was said
you're a bad patient you're you're
diverting your drugs you're overusing
your medicine you're out of my practice
well when you kick an opiate addict out
they're going somewhere and they're
going somewhere cheaper and better and
that was heroin
well what do you think the solution to
all this is because there's a lot of
talk about you know putting a lot of
government funding behind things and you
know it doesn't look like there's a very
clean solution and there's always
throwing money there's not and I want to
say to that that the the the soil in
which this thing take took place was
about us
right I mean there's a III I don't know
how else to describe it except to say
and this is a deeper conversation that
we are in the midst of a deep spiritual
vacuum in this country if not a crisis
and in a world where life has no meaning
and the interpersonal experiences void
and painful you're going for obvious
you're going for something yeah you're
going for par going for something try to
relieve it that's a different problem
you're the problem terms a solution your
question of a solution is very
controversial I spoke to the head of the
addiction program at Harvard just
yesterday for a podcast coming out soon
and he and I both believe that there
they've got to get behind mutual aid
societies which are available in every
corner in our free and he's publishing a
cochrane study that's going to show that
the outcome that these treatments mutual
aid societies like 12-step and smart
we're carving these sorts of things are
as effective or more so than any other
treatment in terms of sustaining
abstinence if abstinence is a realistic
goal
professional services are necessary and
be required but here's a free service
that is a good scientific basis it has
evidence basis in science and it's a
good treatment we got to get behind that
there are replacement therapies out
there like suboxone a methadone that
people are scaling up and I and I'm for
that it's just the excessive enthusiasm
is deeply concerning to me if you got
opiate addiction there I go to Opie
addiction we'd be trying to work on an
abstinence based program because you
wouldn't be able to do what you do
without being off everything
unfortunately we're taking half measures
with a lot of patients and and that may
be required they've made up yet there
may not be a realistic possibility of
surviving this disease and attaining
abstinence so as yes I'd like to go back
actually to the first thing that you
said I think that there there is a
deeper and more involved conversation
than yesterday obviously the residents
medical exactly it's it's interesting
but but it's you know treatable this
thing this thing III really for me
spirituality exists between humans I
sort of a Martin Buber
I did and now yeah I am though and and
although his thinking is kind of I think
more neurobiological about it and then I
do the way Boober thinks philosophically
about him but I do think that there's
something magical about the human
relationship the human experience and I
think there's a lot more that goes on
between and amongst people than we yet
even know and with that landscape of
connectedness and intimacy and parenting
and family has been forsaken for about
sixty years if enough forsaken demean
and the result has been a group of
adults that are empty and if you're
empty and you can't find meaning in
other people in relationships of being
service to other people are contributing
to society I don't know what we're doing
here so why do you think that happened
why do you think that 60 years ago there
was this breakdown in sort of
interpersonal really I have my own
theories I'd like to hear you does the
III will at some point I'm in this
conversation I don't have to tell you
about my theory but not theory but the
theories about how interpersonal
connectedness yes works narrow
biologically but why it happened my
suspicion
what you spend thinking about why you
know I mean if it's why my suspicion is
it was some sort of reaction of the the
world wars of the first half of the 20th
century that those were so traumatic and
the children of those wars somehow that
trauma was rained down upon them at the
same time we decided families or not
important relationships aren't important
or families don't matter or it takes a
village or whatever it is I mean
families are the cornerstone of
everything and have always been
throughout human history and every
culture on throughout time and whenever
that has fallen apart it has been to the
detriment of the society I can only
think of you know only extraordinarily
totalitarian systems like Sparta pulled
that off and they didn't pull it off for
long otherwise it is about the family
and we developed some sort of spiritual
some sort of philosophical political
idea I can't really think of where it
started or why it happened but it
certainly was there the 60s and 70s I
was like my theory so my theory is that
there I agree with you that in the
aftermath of both world wars there was
an existential angst and sort of washed
across the land but I think that a lot
of that existential angst had to do not
only with decline of religion which you
can see statistically taking a nosedive
after World War two but also having to
do with this unfulfilled longing for
community that had once been filled by
either religion or a bunch of bad
ideologies so the feeling of communal
purpose was lost and without that
communal purpose we saw ourselves as a
domestic individuals when you read
existentialist philosophy you know it's
always me versus the world right you
read Sartre and everything is about Here
I am in this chaotic universe as this
atomized human being grows it's my will
that's going to shapes it's going to
shape the world around me well that
doesn't leave a whole lot of room for a
connection with other human beings it
does leave a whole lot of room for for
you to be by yourself right and yet
though something unique happened in this
country because go to Italy or maybe not
Italy as a good example but there are
plenty of other certainly Western and
even Eastern European countries where
there was marked decline of religion but
the families remained who families
remained and and they did not have the
same kind of BS that we've had they've
not had it I mean when you go we have
then started filling ourselves with so
many things like money in cars and
extreme activities that that don't fill
that's a never-ending pit that we do
here in this country while there they
still have their families they still
have their family units the the
existentialism you're talking about I
mean you know I don't know how we go
down this path because I hate sergeant
but I would I like Heidegger okay I
don't like him yeah all right but his
philosophy is kind of interesting and
maybe really Husserl's where I believe
and the idea that there can be a
phenomenological explanation of our how
we put experience and being together
that's appealing that's it's interesting
so what so let's dumb that down for
people who don't know any of those
authors so what do you what do you mean
by that okay Oh Cyril wanted to make a
study of experience and being Heidegger
took that to another level
they sort of extrapolated from HUS role
and started talking about a being that
makes an issue of its being meaning the
human being and we're the only being on
earth that really makes an issue of
being and our existence I think
therefore I am it's IIM there yeah I am
I am in the world I'm being in the world
right and in a temporal frame and all
these things come together and he goes
way into outer space with it's a
wonderful intellectual exercise but it's
how we think about neurobiology now in a
way and what I want to say about that
neurobiology is that that we've moved
away from a single skull system you know
in the 90s we talked about the decade of
the brain there is a single skull we're
gonna understand how the brain works
turns out the brain does not work
without other brains and it really is
everything's in an interpersonal context
where does your self emerge but out of a
relationship with mom and dad and it
emerges out of this relationship there's
another phenomenon that is just poorly
discussed which is what people like me
call effect regulation the ability to be
okay on our own skin to be able to
regulate emotions so they're not too
prolonged too intense too negative and
it turns out that the normal interaction
normal frame for that to develop is it
starts with mom it starts being attuned
to and being the object of scrutiny and
learning that brains have content and
learning that when I have a feeling the
mom reflects that back to me on her face
and may offer me some soothing effects
alongside that that that frame of
closeness of intimacy is what that is
is really where
all meanings sort of resides in terms of
feeling good about life and feeling good
about yourself and experiencing yourself
that and then we can move away from that
and the regulate autonomously
well when we've been traumatized or when
traumas raining through entered
intergenerationally that close frame
become dangerous a lot of lot of
unpleasant material gets rained through
if not shattering material if physical
abuse sexual abuse obey intimate
whatever it might be and so the frame of
closeness in which we can find so much
meaning and satisfaction becomes a
dangerous place that we don't go to okay
so one I want to have you expand on that
a little bit in one second first I have
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so there's nobody on the
planet like you
thank God I mean could anyone stand to
of you but you need your own mattress
okay you need a mattress that is built
for you working with the world's leading
sleep experts you like sleep developed a
mattress that is customized to your
specific height weight and sleep
preferences so you can have the best
sleep of your life at an unbeatable
price here's how it works you go to
helix sleep calm you fill out they're
two minutes sleep quiz you'll design
your custom mattress they can even
customize each side for you and a
partner in 2018 helix sleep is taken
customized sleep to the next level with
the helix pillow they're all new pillows
are fully adjustable so you can achieve
perfect comfort regardless of sleep
position or body type thousands of
five-star reviews we use them at the
Shapiro household we actually took a
helix sleep mattress and you get in the
mail you unfold it and it just inflates
right in front of you we took a more
expensive mattress moved it out of our
room because our helix sleep mattress is
so good all you have to do is go to
helix sleep comm slash been guest right
now and you'll get up to 125 bucks
toward your mattress order that's helix
sleep comm slash been guest because I
have a guest for up to one hundred and
twenty five dollars off your mattress
order again that's helix sleep comm
slash been guest you'll definitely enjoy
the helix sleep mattress it's really
terrific okay so it's why I I know you
just interviewed Jordan Peterson is why
I love him so much because he he would
had secured disagree with anything I've
said so far but he takes all of this
into a sort of a deeper frame and he has
a religious overlay to it an
anthropological overlay and looks for
the patterns of human behavior that are
sort of reflective of what our
neurobiology is and what I was thinking
about is how we've sort of I know what
I'm jumping all the way to this but I'm
gonna go is we we've missed we've missed
in terms of understanding the human
experience we've become to relativistic
in the sense that we just look at the
superficial blush and that really asks
the question that why do you must do
that
why are they like that what why did the
Aztecs tear somebody's heart out and
throw it down the stairs every morning
oh it's because the Sun they believe the
Sun worker oh okay okay okay then stop
there then as opposed to oh my god this
was a population that had something
called a codex which was a systematic
way to create a warrior by abusing the
crap out of children I mean vicious
abuse and when you take a bunch of
people that are severely abused and you
put them together they have a hard time
not acting their aggression out on one
another but if you focus that aggression
out there in somebody that you sacrifice
every day then there's this sort of a
catharsis that goes on within the mob
now we're okay today we did so that one
and I I was I mentioned before before we
started before the had cameras heated up
that I wanted to mention human sacrifice
and it to me it's an informative
phenomenon about the human being
that no one ever looks at and it's in
plain sight here at all times and that
is that if you look at every print of
religion you find him as Accra Feist
right and it's always there it's always
round and then and then it sort of
started in Judaism it started
percolating over - well we'll have an
animal substitute for the human yeah
that's right and but I mean if you look
at what Abrahamic religion what was
Abraham doing when God sent the angel
down - or grabbed his hand he was going
to sacrifice his son he went to kill his
son it was even part of the ancient
sacrifices that people did and and then
some some hallucination or whatever came
through to him and it changed everything
in that moment no more human sacrifice
until evidently we started getting into
it again with our aggressions and then
we decided well there's this one guy but
we'll kill this one guy died for us and
so now we don't have to do anymore that
cuz we can focus on the one guy we drink
his blood and eat his flesh and stuff
and do these cannibalistic things and
help us feel better whatever it is deep
in that is this primitive primate stuff
that we never really look at what's the
real question becomes okay so how did we
get from there to here right because of
the here being a civilization where we
oppose human sacrifice for example
because they're all we've learned to
focus at a channel it in ways that have
gotten us through periods of history
where it could have been a problem right
but then the real
is why in our particular civilization
for example so for example I don't think
that all civilizations have developed an
aversion to human sacrifice quite to the
same extent obvious an aversion to it
yes I mean what's your version peoples
people have a guy in a cross they pray
to it I mean well that's that's that's a
constant reminder of humans are people
who are saying that it is good to go out
and participate in is that by focusing
now there's one guy that did this is
sort of the point that I'm trying to
make which is that the the
judeo-christian tradition in attempting
to eradicate human sacrifice right there
the Bible is very harsh about human
sacrifice it's one of the big things and
it's one of the big puzzles about
Abraham so the traditional Jewish read
on that is that this was Abraham's
struggle is he's being told to do
something he knows is immoral because
God has already told him it's immoral to
do this right and then and then he and
then he doesn't go ahead and do it
presumably because you know he's not
supposed to do it and God does it so I
have I have my own sort of understanding
of that a kind of critic berry and
understanding biological interpretation
but the point is there's an
anthropological thing no question and so
it's deep right brown and the only point
that I'm making is we somehow got from
people who sacrifice each other on the
steps of giant temple just to the place
where we have such a innate now almost
innate abhorrent of this idea but it
didn't you take everywhere right because
the because the fact is that there you
know 70 years ago there's a human
sacrifice of literally tens of millions
of beings and we're fine with that you
know I'm a genocide and how you know
well look look at my theory my theory
would be that the reason that we're able
to focus and not be that way is because
of families become because our
experience in development and our
experience of self and other and the
ability of build effect includes the
experience of love and ultimately if we
do enough connection or though the
people we develop something called
empathy and with empathy no way we're
going to do stuff like that right so
that's the hot that's the highest order
human development is deep empathy of
other people to be able to really
appreciate the people's contents of
their minds if you're being traumatized
and beaten or in war or you're living in
you know horrible circumstances you're
gonna be prone to aggression so how do
we balance these two needs this need for
family and this need for community and
this need for interaction with the fact
that we live in an individual right
society
suggest that you as an individual are
the highest point of our system how do
we build a system that balances these
two these things I think we distinguish
you know what's healthy and what's
politically proper right it's healthy to
be a part of a community it's healthy to
sacrifice on behalf of the community my
rights and privileges should be as an
individual but I think we've even gone
way too far with that I mean the fact
that you walk outside the street you
find a homeless encampment those people
are not that we're allowing those people
those people are not capable of there
are a lot of mental the percentage of
mentally ill among the homeless
extraordinarily severely mentally ill
and we're allowing them and and I've
been through the experience number of
times where you get them and treat them
and they look back who the hell let me
still right there angry so their civil
liberties are being productive I mean
that's way too far and by the way you're
gonna is gonna be an infectious disease
outbreak here in Los Angeles this summer
off of these encampments I promise you
it's not going to be pretty and so we
have sanitation failure we have human
suffering in the streets we have
inability to intervene on their behalf
to do make them help them and we're some
and we're and we're endangering the
entire population of Los Angeles because
of Sanitation failure what is that yeah
it's gone it seems like the society has
bifurcated into radical individualism
versus radical communitarianism and the
the in-between has sort of disappeared
so I don't think the radical
communitarianism really knows what they
mean by that yet yeah they even that
feels sort of like a narcissistic acting
out like what it's radical
communitarianism but I'll be in charge
yeah exactly that's exactly right you
know people who are who are pushing
radical communitarianism will completely
deny any of the possibilities with those
things going bad because obviously how
could possibly go bad I'm gonna be
running it it'll be great and again and
and right it's different this time cuz
I'm running in a brain and the I'm
that's running it has not read history
right I guarantee you because I can't
think of a time in history where it
didn't go back right and that's one of
the things that I find so fascinating
about the American Founding in
particular because the American ideology
from root was that it was your job to
those government's job to stay out of
your way but it was your job to be
virtuous this was the balance virtuous
ants and educated so you lived up to the
responsibility of self covered right is
it in George Washington talks about this
and that all the founders talked about
it was it was so great a so G and
what we're forsaking it yeah we don't
even we don't people aren't even aware
and and both sides were forsaking it on
the one side we say you don't need
virtue all you need to just find your
bliss do what you want to do other
people are objects that's that's fine we
deny that that's what we're doing but in
reality there's a lot of that going on I
see I'm sure you see it much more in
terms of broken interpersonal
relationships in terms of that means
it's out of control
and this is what I get so many letters
from people who listen to my show and I
don't talk about this stuff particularly
often on my show but because I'm younger
and because I talk about my relationship
with my wife and all this I get a lot of
letters from people who say I have a
really screwed-up relationship with with
this other person and typically that's
happening because they're not even
talking to one another they're talking
past one another they're not seeing each
other as independent human beings with
the set of values and then they're not
basing their relationships off that
shared value at all yes and yes and yes
but a lot of what you're describing is
shared intellectual experiences which is
again about listening to each other and
appreciate you those values and points
of view but there's a deeper piece but
they're not even experiencing each other
as holy they're you're the other
person's mind having real agency and
content it's just sort of somebody that
I use to feel better you know so I'll
ask you to ask you a practical dating
question they're gotten a lot so this is
fun I mean as long as I got to read the
practical dating question that I get a
lot is should people who have different
value systems or different religions for
example date each other so my typical
answer on this yeah is know is that you
should is that if you want to have a
long-lasting relationship with somebody
you're both gonna get old and wrinkly
and you're both gonna not be as handsome
and pretty as you once were and you're
not gonna be sexually attracted to that
person as you once were but what you see
from the studies is that levels of
commitment committed love go up over
time and levels of infatuate love go
radically down after the first six seven
months and so if you actually want to
build a committed love then that has to
be built on a shared purpose which can
only be found in a shared set of values
so that shared purpose I'll go with you
all the way there okay but but shared
sets of values can be developed in the
relationship and the family that's
stablishing right but if you have to bet
are you gonna bet on people who share
values Tyler Lee - I'm good
I'm gonna give defer to my host which is
that if you look at common scripts
things tend to go better life scripts
family scripts family of origin scripts
things where everything's already sort
of self-evident to one another that 10
to help relationships go along but but i
but having said that of course the
exceptions are always the radical
differences where people form these new
phenomenological experiences together
and that's very rich and it's dangerous
you're right there may be a risk reward
ratio is the risk for a ratio but I
wouldn't discourage somebody from that
just based on that for any more reason
that I would discourage you and I from
having a good dialogue you know yeah but
I don't think we should get married just
breaking it now there goes the rest of
the show the big the big reveal at the
end I mean I can't believe I put so so
let's talk a little bit about you know
your experiences I wanna get back to the
deep philosophy stuff cuz this is the
fun stuff yeah alright let's talk a
little bit about your experiences in the
media because you know you're you
politically are I would say kind of
libertarian issue yeah well it's so
funny I always thought I was recently
I've been Republican I've been Democrat
and then I thought I'm independent so I
registered independent what do you think
happens when you register independent
it's an actual party here unless you're
careful you guys assigned to the
American independent party so I think
that's actually one because I was gonna
I was gonna go libertarian I thought man
I would change who I could vote for and
seven I'm not really a libertarian but I
kind of am and and my daughter who's
pretty way left said I will do really
Rotarian you're just your right wing
that I'm like I'm not and then I started
talking on the radio about solving the
homelessness problem and I'm concerned
by the lack of government functioning
yeah basic functioning people started
going to me Leo Terrell yeah of course
Leo goes to me goes who do you want
solve that problem government yeah go
yeah yeah he goes
government mr. libertarian with the
government so oh man am i right so the
libertarian philosophy I mean I consider
myself fairly conservative slash
libertarian and I think that most
libertarians there there's different
branches and you and I agree on this
like I like the Fed I think the Fed you
may not like anybody but when I like
freedom well and I think we've lost the
little freedom and liberty is what this
country was about I mean and we just
lost the value in that as though that's
the self evidence given for everybody
and and I think people are looking to
take away other people's freedom in the
name of not sure what self-realization
self esteem
flexing their own ideologies and and if
you ever look at where ever ideologies
prevail in human history humans suffer
wherever ideology is the prevailing wind
blows it does not go well for people and
all I'm concerned about is that people
should thrive that's all I'm concerned
about and and I believe mostly that's
what most people want the vast majority
I would say it's just how we get there's
what we disagree on and that we can't
talk about that is really distressing
because I just want humans to do well I
want them to thrive let them all to
thrive and I do with a lot that really
have trouble thriving drug addicts
narcissist uh it's very difficult for
them yet we get them we get them it's an
interesting experience so doing here's a
question for you do we know enough about
psychology to use psychology as a guide
when it comes to policymaking because if
you look back at sort of the history of
the use of psychology like there's
there's a whole wing of people right now
who say if we just thought
scientifically about things if we just
brought all the data to bear then policy
would inevitably arise and you look back
at the self-esteem movement the
self-realization movement which was
based on a fair bit of bad science
and it just manufactured an entire
generation of people who were incapable
of functioning outside the realm of I
have to be in my own little bubble I'm
gonna let you answer the question but
first I wanna say thank you to our
sponsors over a policy genius so the
truth is a healthy 35 year old can get
half a million bucks in coverage for
less than $30 a month so what are you
waiting for I understand you think
you're never gonna die you're wrong you
are okay and when you do then your
corpse will not be cold on the floor yet
before your family starts paying free
poo and it will make them poor so what
you actually need to do is go get some
life insurance right now and getting
life insurance does not have to be
complicated because of policy genius
policy genius is the easy way to compare
life insurance online in just five
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance placed
over twenty billion dollars in coverage
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you've been thinking
about getting life insurance go to
policy genius com it's the easy way to
compare the top insurers and find the
best policy for you again save time and
money and hassle and it's free over a
policy genius again comparing life
insurance doesn't need to be a pain in
the neck check it out policy genius all
right so I'm fascinated by social
sciences right I really love reading
available
the people that are in that space and
trying to make sense of things but
technically they're not really sciences
right you you can't do
placebo-controlled studies you can't do
it crit hypothesis and create an
experiment on giant human populations
and then have a null hypothesis and you
can't do science and there in the real
sense of doing science and it's in
itself sort of infinitely complex right
and so here it is something we can't do
science it's infinitely complex we can
be informed in our decision-making by
psychology and we can sort of see if we
can help but guide good decision-making
but to have it be the sort of 1984 style
you know the way politics is or history
ISM is created no no no absolutely not
and and I do personal experience of this
just recently when it when you know when
Trump was coming on the scene I was
trying to understand I couldn't get it I
was like why what's this guy for you I
and people were there's a lot of
enthusiasm and then he's elected and
then people are asked me to evaluate his
mental health and he's manic me the
other thing she is and and and I started
sort of looking at his personality and
his you know mood stuff and I thought
wow this is good or bad I don't know
it's too complex and then I thought oh
my goodness hmm my very favorite
President had all these same
characteristic Teddy Roosevelt was the
same guy same you know you couldn't sit
and have a conversation I mean don't you
have to walk through in Central Park
with him or Washington DC or whatever
because he was so manic he couldn't sit
still he had some later in life some
real problems because of that that
bipolar stuff but as president it was
spectacular
it was crazy it's not a crazy making but
it ended up because of his judgment and
because of who he is as human being a
because of his instincts and and the way
he adjusted to some of the decisions he
made and and the philosophy and the
intent and the thinking going forward
Teddy Roosevelt ended up where it needed
to go and and and the same is true like
in not that this is kind of weird
sidebar but you know in medicine we make
decisions you make your decisions based
on your instinct and your informed by
your experience you don't expect to be
rights necessarily you
a back-up plan and you watch and you
adjust and you think and you can you're
careful and you set the table around the
decision you made so you make sure that
things don't run amok that's what
presidents are supposed to do I think
and that takes a lot of energy and it's
a lot of leadership in a way that I've
been thinking willingness to take risk
and trial and error yeah it's a kind of
a leadership that we've not seen lately
it's rather than okay well it's a good
thing I don't know I don't know but
certainly science is an influence so I
mean in that vein you know one of the
things that is becoming clear is that
one of the reasons our politics is
broken is because everyone is tempted to
jump to psychologically diagnosing one
another so what you see in the what you
see so much in the public debate is
you're saying X the real reason you're
saying X is because you really believe Y
or because you're crazy or because you
suffer from a narcissistic personality
disorder or and and so the question is
how much do you as a medical doctor how
much of that do you think is appropriate
in the public sphere well it's it's
inappropriate it's okay for a physician
or psychologist to talk about in
generalities in cases like that but to
say you're thinking X because of Y for
even for a well-trained person no not
unless you've spent years in the couch
of that person and for a non-dream
person do it is sort of the yeah and the
reason I ask is because I think that a
lot of this reliance on sort of junk
science has become very easy in the
media it's a good way to dismiss your
opponent on the basis of sort of example
I'm not sure right here with someone I'm
sure so what so in this last election
cycle there was it there was constantly
what you would hear from people is that
the real reason that people were voting
for Donald Trump is because they were
crazy or because they had suffered when
they were children or because they were
poor and there was a wide variety of
people who voted for Donald Trump I
didn't vote for Donald Trump I doubt
that you voted for Donald Trump but but
the attempt to kind of diagnose
everybody who is opposite you as
suffering from some sort of personality
disorder actually has pretty deep roots
going all the way back to the post World
War two kind of Erich Fromm school of
diagnosis where there is the
authoritarian personality and if you
support from because you have an
authoritarianism propria tor is it just
a lot appropriate it's false but but it
really you know really has echoes of you
something much more sinister which is
labeling people as your ex your whatever
your other your other whether it's
psychological or gene color religion or
philosophy whatever it might be
the tribalism is just insanely it's so
prevalent and it's so much a part of how
our brains work it's had some
evolutionary adaptive advantage to it
but it's running them up right now for
some reason I can't quite figure out why
we got here right so let's talk about
the media a little bit because in that
realm you were basically tossed off of
Siena and headlines so I was not it
turns out I was not a believe I was
which is interesting I you and I had a
little conflict once on Adams show me an
atom at your show and you were telling
me that the news was so biased I was
like man I no one's ever told me what to
say or not to say everything which was
true rat HLN we were sort of doing true
crime and sort of see MBD stories in the
news and no one ever ever came to me
about the way I should present my
opinion or the or the news seems like a
different era and and I and you assured
me that I was not even I started
thinking about I thought well yeah I
guess those guys kind of have their own
point of view and he just kind of does
come across but it's not affecting me
and I don't feel like it's a system-wide
sort of institutionalized sort of
mandate of any type it just didn't these
were just these personalities those the
guys they hired and I guess that's what
they like well then they decided to stop
my show okay then I was on the radio
no no then I was on I was on down
letting it down I was on dilemma show
and he said let's do analysis of Donald
Trump's personality I went all right and
I started and I had thought of this
Teddy Roosevelt thing at the time I said
you know business people can be very
hypomanic he's got all these - manic
qualities but and there's no doubt some
narcissism like all politicians and and
but it I don't see malignant narcissism
because his relationship with his kids
is too good and the kids would not be
putting up with that if there's really
malignant narcissism and then I went on
Teddy Roosevelt who really was a blow
job you know you don't know just because
somebody is one thing doesn't mean
they're make a bad leader a bad
president and I was sort of making that
point I talked for probably 10 minutes
on on their air the next morning my
radio at KBC and my radio guy who you
know drew Hayes just goes hey that was
pretty good do 30 seconds for
on our website and went okay so I did it
in 30 seconds and as I was getting up
and he goes you should really balance
that out do you have 30 seconds on
Hillary and I go yeah they just released
her medical records today and it really
bothered me what the doctors were doing
so I did 30 seconds on not for health on
the seriousness of her health and the
and the kinds of decisions the doctors
are making which was bizarre
it was it whenever I see weird
decision-making by a physician I was and
it's a celebrity I know that I know it's
the doctors you know being addled by
taking care of celebrities and sort of
little slippery dictate I mean I just
looked at Michael Jackson look at Prince
I mean just it's just everywhere it
happens all the time and so I was just
being critical of the the care she was
getting well Drudge picked that up and
they they portrayed it as finding a
doctors brave enough to say Hillary's
sick now what I said but then CNN picked
up and they came down on me like a ton
of bricks I mean it was intense so it's
time when you're diagnosing Trump at the
moment he said anything about Hillary
Clinton and I thought wow that that's
pretty telling
I I was I was shocked and surprised by
that and was already decision are being
made to stop the show so it was not like
we're gonna fire just like like listen
this is a very difficult time and he was
upset people were like calling me and I
was like it's dumb I don't wanna be the
middle this so I'm out so I just didn't
say I think now they announced two weeks
later that I'd stopped the show well the
world social media went haha see so say
they went from crucifying me because I'd
say anything to her anything at all
negative about Hillary's to her world
was was mobilized and then they became
the sacrificial I became the scapegoat
for everybody by having lost my job and
everyone sort of felt good
decided with me even though none of it
had actually happened none of it was
true and and I told I called HLN that
the brass I said let me let me
straighten this out I don't have any
hard feelings this isn't what happened
let me straight now yeah interesting
well I think that one of the things that
that you know to bring some of this full
circle one of the things that is clearly
happened is that the level of
polarization in politics is leading to
an enormous amount of anger and that's
leading to an enormous amount of
reactivity and I think that's so
uncomfortable it is
necessary to in the the level of of just
I mean if you you have a huge following
on Twitter but you don't spend an awful
lot of time on Twitter so dangerous it's
so scary for me to say anything is it
just you just completely that's exactly
right it feels like there's a swarm that
just was my you know I wrote that book
on narcissism the the mirror effect and
I wanted to put an entire chapter
actually broke most of it about other
periods of history where narcissism had
emerged so prominently and and every
time I was looking at pre-revolutionary
France times like that and when you see
a lot of narcissism a lot of childhood
trauma that a lot of narcissism and
again that's because of are destroyed
family we have lots of traumatized kids
you see mob mobs developed so are you
concerned that that's what's gonna
happen next
it is it social media is mob behavior
it's happening now they don't think that
breaks out anywhere furthers that
restrict itself to social media we've
had a few little outbursts we you know I
don't think you're gonna snow I don't
think it's gonna be big mobs and I think
I think I feel like we're on the
backside of some of it a little bit in
something doesn't feel like it's calming
down I think that what one of the things
that's happened is that the the mob
mentality has become so obviously tribal
that people are now rebelling against
the tribalism it's become so extreme
that there's there's this push against
it so I see that mostly in the reaction
to identity politics so I see that there
are a lot of people right now where if
you state a fact people will immediately
accuse you of being a sexist racist
bigoted homophobic you say for example
that these statistics that are usually
cited about the wage gap are just plain
wrong or if you suggest that there are
biological differences between men and
women because there are biological
differences between men and women
obviously every doctor ever has to
diagnose somebody I mean that's not
ecologist it's so absurd I mean I was
hearing from a doctor friend of mine
that there was a transgender person who
came in and the hospital had been
instructed that instead of that person
writing down their biological sex on
their form they should instead write
down their gender they should read their
perceived biological sex that perceived
gender and so the person came in and if
they had not done they were complaining
of lower stomach pain well I mean you're
gonna get wildly different diagnosis
based on whether that is a man or a
woman if it's lower stomach pain and yet
if you say so much is that there are a
bunch of people who are willing to come
down on you and just destroy I don't
understand
why we can't say that there are
populations that have been ill served
because of science or because of lack of
sensitivity to certain things and now
let's talk about the science and and
let's hope that let's state up front
that we don't want that science to be
used to marginalize or condemn or it be
used improperly to hurt other people but
let's just discuss the science how else
do we do we create equality unless we
understand the differences that it's
it's I mean Lincoln Lincoln said it he
said he goes because we're not equal in
all respects he said it the
lincoln-douglas debate debates but it's
about creating a level playing field an
environment where everybody has equal
opportunity equal probability of success
any probabilities not there they say at
least a right to success everybody has
it is an equal there no bars in the way
in other words I would I would say even
if we can you know if we know the
differences and some people needle to
help or something we can talk about
helping it if there's a biological
difference that we can discuss or a
scientific phenomenon that is relevant
to helping one group out versus another
or keeping another group alright
whatever it is let's just discuss the
science because if we can't discuss the
science we're not in reality anymore and
then this is what I'm saying with people
this is why I say I think there's a
unifying moment that's happening because
people on the political left you know
Sam Harris who is a Hillary Clinton
acolyte and it's a voter and and he was
basically thrown out of good company by
people like Ezra Klein because they had
the temerity to say that the IQ studies
that exist about group differences are
valid he was not saying that they're not
environmentally cause he was just saying
that they're just the raw data show that
there are differences in IQ between
goods science has been used historically
to keep down unfairly that population of
course none of those studies has been
but that has nothing to do with what Sam
was saying if the science is too
provocative or too dangerous to be
discussed I don't know what we do it but
we still need a mechanism to discuss it
well science cannot what country am i
living in where science can't just be
discussed with without it resulting in
ad hominem attack it's almost like there
was a chain of thought that happened
where people said okay science is gonna
make policy and immediately sign
whatever science comes out that will be
the new guy for policy and then all this
new science came out and people said
well
don't like the policy that we think
would come out of that science will just
cover to the science we won't we won't
do the science anyway when the reality
is as you were saying earlier there
should be a gap between science and
policy and that gap is called ethics and
morality and values and that has to fill
that in that's a pretty deep well that
well to figure out of what we do in
between science and and policy and
that's another area that we as Americans
don't spend a lot of attention and time
thinking about which is I mean I think
virtue ethics people do think a bit
about these days but guiding
philosophies and what's good for
Humanity so let's talk about that in
just a second but first I'm gonna slate
brush your teeth because I mean come on
people brush your teeth the truth is
everybody is brushing your teeth wrong
usually they're not brushing it for long
enough you forget to change your brush
on time this tube to thousands actually
been willing to gum disease and heart
disease that most brands focus on flat
and selling flashy gimmicks rather than
better brushing not quit so what makes
put better
well for starters quip is an electric
toothbrush that is a fraction of the
cost of bulkier breath timer exactly
that's exactly right he's telling you
the truth people ok the reality is the
quips built-in timer helps you clean for
the dentist recommend in two minutes
with guiding pulses to ensure that you
are reminded once to switch sides next
clip subscription plans are for your
health not just convenience they deliver
new brush heads and a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five bucks including free
shipping worldwide and quip comes with
the mount that sections rights your
merit and on sticks you can use it as a
cover for hygienic travel wherever you
take your teeth and finally everybody
loves quip everybody likes some Oprah
likes them time likes them doctor drew
likes them come on the American Dental
Association likes them plus they're
backed by a network of over 20,000
dentists and hygienists and hundreds of
thousands of happy brushers use quip
every day so quip starts at just 25
bucks if you go to get quip comm slash
been guest right now you'll get your
first refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush get your first
refill pep refill pack free again at get
quip comm slash been guest that spelled
GE tqu IP comm slash been guest and get
that first refill pack for free okay so
now we get into the very very deep stuff
that narrow so how what was her guiding
philosophy do you think people ought to
use the pace or lean back I have found a
great starting point and for some people
for the finishing place to is is
Aristotle I think he kind of figured
things out and and I like the way he
approached science he was of empiricist
I think that speak empiricism might I
think that the pragmatists have a role
to I think I'm a very pragmatic
pragmatism needs to come back again
we're with a pragmatic outcome of what's
good for humanity human beings needs to
take would take a seat at the table see
why you enjoyed and Peterson get along
yeah as well but but but I do believe
that a great way to think about a lot of
things was figured out by Aristotle he I
mean you know the whole concept of
eudaimonia right which is we now think
in terms of eudaimonic happiness versus
hedonic happiness right the happiness
literature is all very lacking because
I'm not sure in this country we know
what we mean by happiness because we
think I kept telling first I first when
I first started seeing happiness
literature I was like Jesus my heroine
acts are happy 8:00 a.m. when they get
that it that's happy man that's not what
you're talking about it's leading a
certain kind of life really and leading
a certain kind of life may not always be
comfortable and it may not always be
hedonic you have a positive hedonic tone
but it certainly should always be you
demonic in the sense that there's
something more nourishing there's
something more fulfilling and one of the
interesting things about about
Aristotle's sense of eudaimonia which
was he you know he had teleology and
everything why humans exist that you may
exist for eudaimonia i think we miss
translated it as happiness for many
years I think it's actually sort of a
thriving or nourishing or doing living
well or something but virtually in
accordance with the right reason well he
did say that yeah yeah he he he that
sort of was a sidebar on this where I
want to go with this is a little bit
different which is that he felt in order
to be armed properly to be able to
achieve eudaimonia you needed to have a
certain amount of phronesis
wisdom a certain amount of tech name
skill he had a couple other criteria
that didn't don't stay with me right now
as much but i but for a nice distance
killer that we're very important and and
and this is the part that people miss
they think that in that that if I'm
leading a certain kind of life most
people will come to the point that
participating with other Hugh
what really gives something nourishing
whether it's raising a family or being
community or you know it being whatever
it is you know it's not necessarily
labeling soup at the homeless kitchen
that's good it's also not being post
bread Brad Pitt's wife's name really is
saving the world that's not that does
not feel that's not that fulfilling it's
good I'm glad she does it but it's not
that fulfilling in the way that having a
set of skills and wisdom to help another
human being was something that they're
struggling with that's why I'm so
grateful to be a physician I have all
that skill and wisdom of experience
right I really am always loaded up and
ready to do something like that I'm very
aware that that that creates if you use
it and use it for good use it to help
others and and and be are aware that
you're gifting somebody something with
it it's tremendously filling it's always
filled you always feel a certain kind of
eudaimonia if i'm hopi 'pl understand
that when i me balance nourishment being
okay and i had to have a few years of
therapy in there to die I did but but
I've always been one of the things I'm
most grateful for is I got this piece I
got this thing to offer and I think we
all got to remember and think about that
so the question is and the reason I
mentioned that the teleology is can you
have eudaimonia in the absence of
teleology can you have the eudaimonia
without that piece where you say it's
virtue in accordance with right reason
and the whole system of aristotle's the
idea of the unmoved mover the idea that
you were created to do certain things
and those things can be discoverable in
the universe by virtue of what those
things are so you as a human being you
are created to reason because this is
what distinguishes you from the animals
and if you are not actually acting in
accordance with that right reason and
and using that right reason in order to
pursue these these naturally seen goals
there's a great book called after virtue
by Alistair MacLean
Anna McIntyre rather and his entire
argument is that what's happened in the
West is that Aristotle's version of
virtue has fallen away and it's been
replaced by this other weird version of
virtue which is basically we define for
ourselves what virtue is so we got rid
of the Greek teleology and we replaced
it instead with this idea that you were
just supposed to be a nice guy and
that's not actually what Aristotle said
what Aristotle is saying is that you
have to act in accordance with your
reason as applied to the highest seeking
zuv
and being so human desires often take a
backseat but human desires do take a
backseat and we have been hedonic for at
least 30 or 40 years but we've also
abdicated our personal responsibility to
figure out our own virtue ethics to the
government and a law yeah I certainly
grew it down I mean and I think that's
why we don't have a practice of that
anymore we just like the nanny takes
care of us yeah and I think that the
reason that I feel you know what what
I'm what I'm often saying is this Athens
in Jerusalem is the Strauss Ian model of
what built Western civilization is there
the the ethic of judeo-christian values
combined with this Greek teleology this
search for reason which unites in
philosophers like Aquinas where he's
clearly trying to apply Aristotle to the
Bible that this is what has created
Western civilization which is where I
was triangle earlier in the discussion
about the movement from human sacrifices
that you have to combine a certain set
of values and that people are actually
not very good at discovering their own
sets of values that when people are
trying to discover their sets of values
very often what they come up with is
either damaging to themselves or
damaging to others or a way to try and
control other people and what I mean by
that is that yeah yeah I mean I think
that virtually the entire history of
humanity between 1850 and 1950 is pretty
good evidence of that but we try to
arrive our own virtues we become may any
access and now that we become maniacs
but that we tend to prioritize our
feelings are our priorities or over
other people's priorities it's hard to
get to a place where you are
prioritizing the larger concern of
somebody else's humanity as an
individual human being over even or you
over even over your utopian wishes right
ideology arises from your attempts to
reach utopia yes it's difficult to art
we have a motivational system and it's
difficult for us to escape it and if
it's charged up or if it's unregulated
watch out and the reason that I say this
is because well when I went to Harvard
Law School our first day at Harvard Law
I remember Elena Kagan was the Dean
she's now in the Supreme Court and she
ushered us into this beautiful mahogany
room just gorgeous room 500 kids there
all of us at the top the cream of the
crop that people had done the best on
the lsaps which means we're very smart
and we're all there and she turns to the
entire audience listen you guys don't
have to worry the competition's over
this isn't the paper chase everything is
good you're all gonna get jobs and then
she said the part
part that really disturbed me if she
said and now you are going to be the
Masters of the Universe we have this
number of justices on the Supreme Court
we have this number of people who are in
the Senate we have this number of people
who are in the House of Representatives
you guys are the smartest you're the
best you know the most and you're gonna
be the ones who are making all the rules
and I just thought to myself well this
is how every bad thing in the history of
humanity is happening right here I
mentioned hubris 45 minutes ago that's
hubristic that that's hubris whenever
you think you know more than everybody
and by the way you know is a natural
there's a very natural sort of a em from
what she said to well I'll do whatever I
want because I'm I'm that guy I'm the
guy Superman but I'm gonna tell you how
to do it because I'm the best of right
that is a horrible horrible feature of
human beings that is not how we should
work and so how do we restore the
humility that's necessary we talk about
all the things we're missing right now
humility gratitude break down a family
structure focus on atomistic
individualism how do we get back to to
basics here what are some practical
things that you think we ought to be
doing right now
who's we anyone anyone who's suffering
from a feeling of purposelessness a
feeling of anger over owns that don't
matter your macho man you know the
literature shows it's very strange but
I've got up I'm gonna piece together a
bunch of different little things first
thing you do is make your bed
the happiness literature is very clear
that if you start your day by making
your bed you're more like you happy and
it tends to set a tone for the day like
as you start doing something get off
your ass start doing something secondly
one thing you can do is to advocate this
rather strongly is to watch the
relationships around you and watch who
you avoid and who you sort of gravitate
towards and start kind of hanging out
with somebody who might not otherwise
does that be somebody you verse it to
but somebody different than you normally
hang with and tell by yourself and find
out about them you will be stunned how
often people have some moments of
clarity about themselves as a result of
something as simple as that it I call it
seeing yourself for the new pair of
glasses self pre-owned we have lots of
delusions and denial and stuff about
ourselves and if we're not happy
and we're in a bad spot we're
contributing to it somehow and and we
can contribute to getting out of it but
if we don't really see ourselves as we
are it's very difficult to do that and I
would attend a nutrition and exercise
all those simple things and I would find
some way to create meaning how can I do
something meaningful not how can I get
happy or how can i how can I make money
but what's meaningful for me and it may
mean listening to podcast and reading
for a while
and figuring out well you know Plato
said that right I said you sit around
you philosophize this sad spot I mean
that's a that's a tough thing to do
especially if you're you're miserable
it's hard to concentrate and stuff but
but but you can you can you can build a
life and I and it's it's really
ultimately it's about others and it's
about who you build your life with and
spending time with people and I'm not
saying it's not going out really in
arousing circumstances I think that's
where colleges have really done young
people a disservice it's all about these
extremely intense parties and drinking
and all hooking up opposite quiet shared
moments thinking talking discussing
things being being present with other
people but be fully present rigorous
honesty it's another thing that is I
found an extremely important practice at
practice you won't do it you know I I
think David the virtue ethicist a bit
Brooks who has some interesting things
to say about developing character and
virtue ethics and you know listen to
these podcasts and see where you can
apply doing better I don't understand
why that's not thrilling for people that
it should be it should be extremely
exciting and and then if you really get
inspired read about your country I mean
there's so much genius in this this
country we have this I am so inspired by
the founding fathers and and yes they're
all of their weaknesses and they're
crazy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they put together out of thin air
in the first time in history a country
based on ideas never happened before and
it just sustained us for 200 plus years
get behind that notion and learn what it
is and see if you can't contribute to it
at whatever that means for you rather
than
I'm not even sure our politicians even
understand the country that they're
serving right that's right particularly
on the state level and and to understand
what it is and to where it was weak make
it stronger but where it was a genius
system and again it was based on
philosophy that's where they looked at
they looked at what had worked and what
hasn't and there's another side bar I'm
gravely concerned about California and
gravely concerned about and here's my
biggest concern if there's a million
reasons to be concerned we've already
got over some of them but direct
democracies never survive throughout
human history and we are very proud in
this state of our referendum system
which is a direct democracy stuff
semester country doesn't understand this
that is destined for failure and it I
think I if I did I think when the
history books are written they're gonna
look at that as the reason the
California implodes and becomes three
states I think we might be three states
sometimes wow I really do i I would have
been mortified by that thought about I'm
gonna have to move to Orange County but
you'll be able to least determine your
future a little bit but but I would have
been mortified by that thought six
months for sure twelve months ago now
I'm starting to think there may be no
other way I'm out well dr. drew thank
you so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it that's you're not gonna
get a more eclectic conversation yes
oh no it's wonderful time feeling
today's it's really fun I love picking
it from every aspect of the tree and
it's wonderful to have you here if you
haven't listened to dr. Drew's podcast
you definitely should go to all 9,000
about dr. commas where everything goes
fantastic so go check out dr. drew com
dr. drew thanks so much for stopping by
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex Singaram audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessica Oliveira and title credits by
Cynthia and hula the ben shapiro show
sunday special is a daily wire forward
publishing production copyright ford
publishing 2018